let's turn to other world news and
police in Afghanistan say at least three
people have died in a blast in the
southeastern region of Cole's province
there's been no claim of responsibility
so far the attack comes just days after
the US and the Taliban signed an
agreement in Doha aimed at ending a
nearly two decades war in Afghanistan
let's get the latest from hajjabdullah
Hameed who's in Kabul Forrest so what
more are you hearing about this attack
and who do we think is behind it hold on
well well we know about the attack is
that there was a blast near a stadium in
the host province and according to the
Interior Ministry three people were
killed and seven others injured now we
don't know who is behind back that
attack it could be some spoilers there
are several armed groups operating in
this country who were against the deal
between the Taliban and the u.s. that
you mentioned signed in Doha two days
ago but even if it were the Taliban does
that that does not breach the agreement
because in that agreement the Taliban
have to hold off from attacking any
foreign troops any military bases where
you have foreign and Afghan troops any
government institutions here in Kabul
and in the provincial capitals but the
ongoing war and against security forces
that is not part of the deal and the
Taliban had said earlier in the day even
though it's not confirmed but there were
reports that they said that the truce
they had over the past week which was
the week leading to that agreement is
now over and they will resume their
normal operations against Afghan targets
right but the Afghan they are reports
that the Taliban the Afghan Taliban who
are threatening not to go to these intra
Afghan talks to the talks were the
government if their fighters 5,000 of
them aren't released yes there are
reports about that we haven't been able
to confirm us we reached out to the
Taliban they said they will get back to
us there is no official state
on their own a website which usually
that's how they communicate to the
outside world but it it could be very
possible that someone said that I mean
the certainly the Taliban who are here
in Afghanistan according to these
reports and that would be probably in
response to what the Afghan President
Ashraf Ghani said yesterday basically
started today by saying well this the
release of detainees has nothing to do
with us we did not commit the agreement
in Doha was signed between the US and
the Taliban but those detainees are in
Afghan jails and this is a matter of
Afghan sovereignty he went on to say
that any kind of concession of that sort
should be negotiated during the intra
Afghan talks if those happen indeed on
March 10th as scheduled now it's it
could be that the Taliban were answering
replying to that I think at this point
we will probably have us and voice I'll
make Helen sad working the phones if
he's not already in Kabul to basically
put pressure on both sides to try to
take a step back and try to reach some
sort of agreement but at the moment
there is a lot of posturing from both
sides I would say it started from the
Afghan government side and that would be
a response from the Taliban how do I
thank you for that update ho table Doha
meet my for a sim Kabul